what's up y'all this is Haley come shoot
with me what's the lab would you say
that you're most Star Struck by the one
time I met J Cole I couldn't even get a
word out and that's never happened to me
before so that would definitely be the
one how would you describe your style An
Elegant Street Wear I love a good calm
fit but I believe in Timeless pieces
what would you say is your favorite pair
of sneakers in your closet I just C the
new like Bad Bunny Adidas cross over
ones what about LSU has surprised you so
far the community the culture the team
everything is so close nit and it's
really like a family and that's so
important for me because I'm so far from
home dream three on three team me Stewie
Marie johanes and arque last but not
least if you were going to try and win a
game of horse what shot would you do
like a little something like
this that's it right there